all right so here's the big idea in 2004
uh this idea emerged from a book The
emerging Democratic majority that said
the country is getting more diverse
diverse people vote Democratic uh it's
getting less white rural uh and old uh
young people also like Democrats more so
the Democrats will experience a winded
their backs by virtue of demographics
that will lead to a sustained majority
and this was born out in part by Obama's
resounding victory in '08 uh his victory
in 2012 didn't completely debunk it but
in many ways your book is the big
fact-based Counterpoint saying whoa whoa
whoa it turns out that that is not
correct because of the fact that now the
single biggest deal in American politics
is not whether you're white or non-white
it's whether you have a college degree
or not is that a fair summary yeah I
think so I I I think that like there in
the wake of the Obama victories there
was definitely a thought process on the
left that said look at all the groups
that Obama won winning young voters by 2
to one winning uh you know these
expanded majorities among
African-Americans doing much better
among Latinos that all these groups are
just growing are going to become more
influential in the years to come and so
uh you know we don't really need to
change our message and we don't need to
moderate our message in order to win um
that we and just wait for the
demographic tides to eventually make it
so that uh you know we are going to see
the end of you know white Christian
conservative America I think was one of
the titles of books you know kind of the
titles of books that came out in this
era but that was a dramatic misreading
of both what Obama actually did and uh
both demographically and uh you know
message wise so um you know what you
actually saw uh you know during the
Obama era was he him appealing effect
very effectively uh to these um you know
Working Class People specifically white
Working Class People in
deindustrializing parts of the country
so he did extremely well in the Upper
Midwest in Midwestern states in States
like Michigan and that we
experiencing um you know we're
experiencing an economic collapse
because the Auto industry uh was
collapsing and he very effectively
promoted the auto bailout in 2012 and
made that a major dividing line in that
election so I think people like to focus
on look at all the things he did with
young progressives right and and
mobilizing young progressives and he did
that but was within a coalition of
Voters who more conservative
temperamentally which was kind of that
white workingclass Midwestern Auto
worker factory worker uh that voted for
Obama and then shift over to voting for
Trump so what happens when uh what
happens in that you know scenario is
that the Democrats start blaming really
start um start attacking um those voters
who you know calling them racists
calling them people who uh you know are
racially resentful but they in fact they
voted for Obama so how how can that be
true it was you know Trump uniquely
spoke to them in the in the same way
that Obama uniquely spoke to them and I
think um you know it's funny because you
mentioned the emerging Democratic
majority and that was really kind of how
it was interpreted right as this surge
of non and Progressive uh voices in the
electorate but um the authors of that
book have a new book out actually that
uh and they have already said like no
this was wasn't going to come true
because specifically our book really
also said you need to worry about the
white working class you need to maintain
hold serve with the white working class
Democrats and they just haven't done so
and in fact the rhetoric towards those
workingclass voters in the midwest um
has been anything but welcoming since
2016 in my view your book uh if I would
to simplify it um here's the message is
that there are a lot of non- colge
educated non-white voters that Democrats
in the political class assume of course
they got to vote for us because we're
the party of the diverse and uh what are
they going to do vote for the
Republicans the Republicans are racist
um but it turns out in real life uh a
lot of nonwhite non colge graduates uh
actually are very into the Republican
party uh where Trump is competing at
parody among Latino populations in
various parts of the country um there's
been a drift towards the Republican
Party among uh asian-americans you can
even see a little bit of it in the black
community albe it from a very very low
base uh and that struck me as the the
underpinning of this is that look if you
just assumed every Latino Asian uh black
voter is going to vote Democrats and
those populations are going to rise then
all set
Democrats and and what you're saying is
whoa whoa whoa if you look at the data
it turns out that Democrats have
increasingly become the party of the
college educated and that if you're a
non-college educated Latino Asian or
black voter you're actually going to be
drifting towards the GOP hence the GOP
becoming this multi-racial Coalition
party uh is that uh did I get that right
yeah I mean I think that um you know
this book and I think I wouldn't say
this book specifically I think reality
has challenged a lot of those
assumptions that um people made about
the electorate so you know specifically
one of the major failings of this uh
demography as Destiny theory was that
Latinos would behave the same way as
black voters have historically as
members of a cohesive identity group
that would move Democratic on the issue
of immigration because they favored more
legal immigration or favored more you
know a more open immigration policy that
included a pathway to citizenship for
illegal immigrants and that was really
kind of the major thinking around 2012
you know that has been proven wrong I
think partly because you sort of
misunderstood it misunderstands the
motivation of most Latino voters most
Latino voters don't see themselves as
part of this unified block of people
they certainly don't see themselves as
Latin X but
see they don't always necessarily see
themselves as as part of this pan Latino
Community right um when you actually
talk to them people say I'm Mexican I'm
Venezuelan but more more often than that
uh they just kind of see themselves as
regular Americans I mean I think in a
lot of places they're very thir you know
you've got people are many of them are
are deeply religious and part of a like
a church Community right and so I don't
think you can mobilize them right on
this sort of identity politic
um but I think that there's also a risk
right where Democrats feel right now
they have a little bit of an initiative
on this abortion issue which I I think
you know to some extent look you can't
argue with the election results in some
of these states that have had referenda
on the issue but I I think they're not
necessarily thinking about how they're
branding and defining their party right
um you know that I think from a
coalitional standpoint you've got a lot
of people who are in within the
Democratic party who have more
conservative views on social issues than
have more conservative views on let's
say economic issues and so long term
when the political you know sugar high
of that issue kind of recedes what are
you left with you're left with a party
that is defined more and more by its
left of center views on cultural issues
than it you know has it had been defined
whereas it had been defined previously
by really standing up for the work
working class who are the majority vast
majority of the country um based on
lines of college educations and on
economics too I would love love love for
the Democratic party uh or any party to
start hitting policies and messages that
would appeal to the non-white non--
college educated workingclass of this
country because if you improve their
lives you're probably doing something
great you're probably doing something
that brings down the cost of housing
bring down brings down the cost of
healthcare brings down the cost of
Education uh makes it more affordable to
be you know the um mother father of a
child make you feel better about the
future so that would make me very very
excited I certainly think that uh I I
was on CNN a while ago and I said look
um you know what people don't like is a
political party as the culture of police
it's like hey you say or do the wrong
thing you use the wrong word you're not
keeping track of the right
terminology then you're you're somehow
in the outs I mean that that that is a
very very uh esoteric message that does
not speak to the non-white working class
like um so so that that's something I
would love to see parties take wisdom um
from you and your
data hey YouTube thanks for watching
please do hit like And subscribe and hit
that Bell if you want to be notified
every time a new episode drops thank
you